these yep that's on good evening
everyone welcome to the Overseas Press
Club of America I'm Patricia crayons the
executive director and of course you
know tonight is our book night for Putin
country a journey into the real Russia
by anne garrels i'm just going to give
you a brief little promo for the OPC
before we get into the program so the
OPC is a group of former and current
foreign correspondents dedicated to
promoting and honoring the best in
international journalism we hold author
book nights like the one tonight an
annual awards dinner and numerous other
programs some of you here attended our
Russia hands reunion a few months ago
where there were over 80 people who used
to cover Russia in the former Soviet
Union we did that with the Herman
Institute at Columbia and we all know
that covering the world has become ever
more dangerous that is why the OPC last
year joined with the frontline freelance
register the committee to protect
journalists other advocacy groups and 95
news organizations to sign principals
protecting freelancers on dangerous
assignments if you are not already a
member of the OPC please consider
joining there's applications on the
table out there we also have a web site
where it's very easy to join and if
you're 29 and under it's only 20 dollars
so I'm not sure we also have we also
have a retired feed rate too so okay so
now on to the program the speaker hears
tonight hardly need any introduction and
garrels was senior foreign foreign
correspondent for NPR for 23 years until
2011 before that she was State
Department correspondent for NBC News
and chief correspondent in my
scout in Central America for ABC News
Putin country is her second book the
first was naked and Baghdad she has won
numerous awards including the courage
and journalism award by the
International Women's Media Foundation
vo in 2003 but the OPC was on to her
before that she won the Whitman basso
award in 1998 which recognizes
international environmental reporting
next to Ana's Ville Keller
he's currently editor-in-chief of the
Marshall project he worked for the New
York Times from 1984 to 2014 as a
correspondent editor and op-ed columnist
as a correspondent he covered the
collapse of the Soviet Union which we
all know was a great time winning a
Pulitzer Prize and and also wrote about
the end of white rule in South Africa
and in from 2003 till September 2011 he
was the executive editor of The New York
Times so bill take it away okay we're
gonna chat for a while at some point
I'll open it to questions from the floor
so if you see me going like this it's
not because I'm bored it's because I'm
trying to figure out how much time we've
got left so that I can squeeze in some
questions from the audience I just I was
really struck the other day when I ran
across this quote from Svetlana
alekseyev it was the 2015 Nobel Prize
winner which I'm going to breathe for
starters and then put on the shelf in
the West people demonize Putin they do
not understand that there is a
collective Putin consisting of some
millions of people who do not want to be
humiliated by the West there is a little
piece of Putin in every one it seems to
me that's not a bad summary of your book
but I think use it let's sit yeah use it
as a blurb on the paperback let's leave
Putin deciphering it for now and start
with why Chelyabinsk okay I heard you
quoted somewhere saying that basically
you threw a dar
map if you did it was a very lucky throw
it was a lucky throw I it just became
clear to me when we were there in 92
when I went back as correspondent for
NPR in 92 and was traveling widely all
the time but I was dropping in on places
that I wanted one place where I could
follow the evolution of people's views
get to know people officials so that it
wasn't just a cursory no one issue trip
and frankly it became a much more
important than I had imagined when in
2011-2012 when the opposition protests
began in Moscow and frankly I think the
Western media focused entirely on Moscow
and it was distorting it you know if you
were looking at if you were reading
forgive me the New York Times or I mean
you would have thought the country was
up in arms but out in the provinces that
was not the case now it's true that
people were scared or at least cautious
but also they there's a bit of Putin in
everyone Putin gave people by the
benefit of high oil prices and gas
prices in 2000 when he came in he gave
people a sense of economic prosperity
for the first time but I'm jumping ahead
but that was and I didn't start thinking
I would write a book but as it as it
went on it became clear that this was
something that was missing from what
people were seeing about Russia and it
was middle Russia middle America we'd
all been focused too much as if we were
writing you know as if Washington was
America and as we now know
there's a strange beast out there that
we may not fully understand one thing I
was curious about is that Chelyabinsk
was a little more isolated than other
provincial cities just because it was
home to the Soviet nuclear program and
you know had extra layers of security I
did throw a dart you're right I mean I
it could have been anywhere it could
have been permit could have been
Yekaterinburg formers faired loss it
could have been you know Yaroslavl it
could have been a reason any number of
places and I couldn't decide but as it
turned out it was a pretty good choice
because it wasn't
I didn't just cover the city but the
region and it bore all the marks of a
Detroit of a you know Pittsburgh of a
Birmingham yeah I mean everything all
wrapped up and it did have the Adhan
Philip that it had been the home of the
the Soviet weapons so there there that
that hadn't been my intention initially
but it wasn't it it was a nice addition
if you will do you think that that up
might also made the people there more
conservative than no you would find in
Yekaterinburg no because actually the
weapons program was quite isolated from
them they didn't know anything about it
until 88 89 it was it was totally you
know in the forest people couldn't talk
about it okay so give us a sort of
overview of Chelyabinsk what kind of a
place is it I mean you said Detroit well
it's a it's a industrial city like all
Soviet cities where the industry is
pretty much in the center of town
because in the early days and it's and
it it also represented and became a
great way to describe the effects of
World War two because Chelyabinsk was
beyond the Urals I mean it's on the far
side of the Urals so it was safe from
him
and it was where they sent suspect
Soviet Germans to work because it was
far away from so they could not be
collaborators it was where the factories
went in order to build tanks and and
became known as tank ogród during world
war ii and this and the population
exploded people were living in
unspeakable conditions during that
period it took a while for all of that
to resolve and the legacy of that was
that there was kind of a pride but there
were and but it didn't make it more
conservative actually and when
Chelyabinsk opened to the West in 92 93
there was huge excitement I mean they
were it was like wow you know I mean and
and I described in the book you know
going the seventh-day Adventist came to
chili ovens and for about about a month
and every night they were in the
communist party theater and every night
they packed it out five hundred six
hundred people now not that they all
came away going yes but and it was all
very I mean it and they gave people
American flags when they quit smoking
after a while most of them women and
only a few they but people came out
saying this is really interesting I mean
they were exploring ideas and they had
an unfortunately delusional idea of what
the West was that it had to be paved in
gold that it was they had the answer to
everything
and if if only Russia could be like the
West everything would be wonderful and
then of course they began to travel even
from Chelyabinsk whether it was a
Turkish vacation or to the Sinai for a
beach vacation or whatever they began to
learn more and more about really what
the rest of the world was like
and at the same time they felt betrayed
that the West was moving NATO closer and
closer to their borders relations were
not going so well and and that's what
Putin really played cleverly on people's
feelings of wait a minute first of all
they felt like betrayed lovers because
they had delusional ideas about the West
second of all the West began to treat
Russia ignoring it and in Russians views
treating it like losers and it was a
toxic combination a lot of your
characters including the most
sophisticated of them are seem to come
across as walking contradictions you
know you have the Jota magazine editor
who dresses like something out of Vogue
but thinks that the West really is
conspiring to bring Russia to its knees
you know you have a lot of characters
who idolize Western culture but feel
humiliated or and defensive about Stalin
for example who becomes more popular by
the day it isn't it's a total
contradiction and one of the most
poignant I think characters is somebody
who really wants to make changes and but
he supports the Putin Putin vertical
just passionately even though that is
what is stopping him from doing what he
wants to make the necessary changes and
and and you can't argue with them I mean
it you sort of reach a dead end it's
like no things have to stay they the way
they are and I think there's an element
a big element there Putin may be not the
best thing that can that came down the
pike but it could be worse and in fact
what's going on in Chelyabinsk now I'm
not I hope I can go back I friends
think that's unlikely there but we'll
see but there's you know on the one hand
you do have this very strict Putin
vertical where it would appear that you
know anyone who goes against him and
anybody who puts their head against the
transom and becomes too popular their
head gets chopped off but there is a
very nasty war going on in chili ovens
between the FSB the heirto the KGB and
the governor's office and it's all about
power it's all about money it's not
about ideology and it is really vile and
it it represents a little bit of where
people say you think Putin's bad it
could be a lot worse
I mean we could really have ultra ultra
nationalists here and they and one of
the things I kept saying to friends is
ok but where the red lines where is it
where the kids will say no the kids are
utterly apathetic and Putin is very
cleverly played the internet they can
download whatever music they want
whatever movies they want for a while
the economy was really doing pretty well
until 2012-13 but now he's able he's
turned it around saying okay the
economy's not doing so well it's because
of the West and and we're going to
become self-sufficient because of this
and stronger there's no evidence of that
yet and it's a big challenge so we'll
see if that happens but the it's you
know it's a the Internet is but on the
other hand the Internet and you know
some poor schmuck who who says I don't
believe in God suddenly gets a sentence
I mean he's
why is he singled out for for posting
this on on the Russian version of
Facebook
and there are any number of people in
more people this year who just first
have been come under the extremism laws
which are all so vague that anybody can
come under them depending on the court
in the region so it's it's a mix it's at
once again a contradiction there's on
the one hand it seems a lot of freedom
the kids say we don't notice notice
anything we can travel you know we can I
mean they live there back in the kitchen
essentially with the Internet hmm talk a
little bit about the church the Russian
Orthodox Church and its the role it's
played in Chile evidence in the maybe
even pre Putin in the Elson years the
church was very slow to sort of get with
the program initially it didn't know how
to deal especially out in Chile ovens
which the Communists had proudly called
a godless region and I mean it was very
scientific there were a lot of it didn't
have as much perhaps presents perhaps as
it might have and some other towns
because people were highly academic and
and and it was sort of really caught
unawares and had no idea how to begin to
be a community activist and reach out
and have Sunday schools and be anything
other than it had been and so a lot of
foreign missionaries pretty savvy chose
targeted chili ovens like the
seventh-day Adventist who had limited
success but a lot of Pentecostal and
Baptist churches went out there and and
did a lot and did a lot early on with
addicts and specifically they were the
first ones to set up any kind of
addiction centers accrued as they may
have been they were better than the
state ones so they they made quite a lot
of inroads but and then the church
having earned a lot of money because it
was getting tax-free cigarettes and
importing tax-free cigarettes and look
managed to and at the end gradually it
became popular and the right thing to do
if you wanted to influence the right
people to support the church build a
church and that has continued but that
it's you know I I was with a professor
and he had asked his kids in at
university he had asked his the kids in
his class okay how many of you were
believers and two-thirds raise their
hands and he said how many of you can
name the four evangelists two out of 40
I mean it's but that doesn't mean to say
that it's necessarily powerless by any
means just because of their ignorance
but it is a knee-jerk I mean everybody
wears crosses now Orthodox Cross says
it's if the Protestant churches had a
farrago when the 90s it's very hard for
them to to have to open new churches the
Orthodox Church increasingly is becoming
more sophisticated in its propaganda and
they have a TV program now in
chelyabinsk and so it's it building what
is the russian orthodox and network
programming look like
pretty boring okay
you wrote a bit about the LGBT community
and and and I've wanted to hear you talk
a little bit about that in part because
Putin has made an article of his sort of
anti Western strategy that you know that
we're trying to sow homosexuality among
the youth of Russia there the whole
business during the Olympics when that
came out what was it like what's it like
to be gay in Chelyabinsk probably better
than most of you would think but not as
but not as great a life as somebody
who's gay would like and I mean there is
a and it's gotten more difficult
I have unquestionably but there is there
are there is a one in particular very
popular well attended gay bar restaurant
that's open on Fridays Saturdays and
Sunday nights where it is packed packed
and it has the funniest best
entertainment in town
I didn't under first night I actually
didn't understand most of it but it was
so camp and so funny and none of the
words were in my dictionary and it's
they're also very careful they there are
bouncers they check people no weapons no
drugs they Pat you down they make sure
there are cameras in the bathrooms they
don't want to be shut down and and
curiously I mean I'm sure they could
find you know if they want to the tax
police anybody can find any reason to
shut anyone down and they haven't so but
I mean it's like really that sort of
interesting for anybody interested in
the arts or whatever in chelyabinsk and
the gay community has a predilection for
liking those things and so a lot of them
are moving to Yekaterinburg where it's
more it's even better or less so there I
mean you can it's it's possible but
where people are if you want to adopt if
you have adopted in the past when things
were a little easier people are afraid
their kids are going to be taken away
from them because of the the law as it
stands doesn't ban homosexuality per se
but it's probably many of I mean I know
many of you know all of this but it bans
propaganda again that is directed at
minors which essentially means you can't
talk publicly about homosexuality
because a minor might hear it
and so it's shut down any discussion see
the upshot of it is that everybody is
sort of back in the closet you don't say
what if if eight years ago you probably
you might have said at work you know or
people might have known
now you're much more careful about about
that sort of thing and the interesting
question is okay what are their feeling
about Americans or Western Europeans
coming in and pushing the gay movement
in Russia many of my friends and
acquaintances I got to know in Russia
said back off you're making our lot
you're you're assuming that we can move
as fast it move tomorrow to where you
are we can't we're where you are forty
years ago and you've got to understand
that I mean remember homosexuality was
illegal until 91 92 I can't remember
exactly the year was and you would be
imprisoned attitudes are still
very conservative even among liberal
Russians who I talked to friends and
Chelyabinsk who are on the way on the
liberal political end of the spectrum
you know and I'd say well what do you
think about this and I don't know anyone
who's gay and you say well what about
Uncle Joe and they go oh just eccentric
I mean it sounds like the conversations
I had with my parents 40 years ago you
know and so the question of how how hard
to press because the things were doing
okay until you know people or some would
say you know people were sort of coming
out able to live openly until you know
there were big demonstrations and it
sort of everybody was pushing the agenda
too fast for not just the government but
for the populace at large one of my
favorite characters in your book is
Alexander of loss off the forensic oh
it's not just because and he's one of my
favorites because he represents it what
I think of as a kind of peculiarly
Russian form of dissident which and
there have been outright to the
barricades dissidents too but he's the
kind of dissident who sort of calculates
how far he can go
occasionally goes a little too far and
gets his fingers burned backs off but
then it but doesn't give up talk a
little bit lots of this is a he he was a
forensic scientist in the Soviet period
how are you doing because we know you
have to know it's a fun answer tonight I
want to leave a little room for people
to ask question that but yeah blasts off
was one of the true joys of being in
Chelyabinsk and I probably left his
office an apartment more drunk than
sober
I have to admit it a devotee of
champagne
I mean of good champagne
and the but he had been a forensic
scientist and when the Soviet Union went
a Russian economy or Soviet Union broke
apart and whatever he and his wife a
doctor were making the equivalent of ten
dollars a month and they couldn't live
on it was very simple so he became a
funeral director and the first and only
one in Chelyabinsk and he was very good
at it
and was very successful and the
government and the local governor and
Mayor of Chelyabinsk and then the
governor or whatever weird to me finally
demanded more and more and more and more
bribes and he finally said no and his
deputy was shot on his way out of the
funeral business
and so blasts off eventually went into
but went back to become the first and
for a long time the only independent
forensics expert in Russia
you'd think given the Putin courts and
this was in the Putin era that you know
not exactly something that you know was
gonna you know he'd where there was
gonna be a huge demand but eventually
judges actually began to call on him
know politically sensitive cases no way
he can have any effect he tried I mean
when kids were killed in in the military
young men were killed in the military
because of the brutal hazing he
investigated those cases very
successfully I mean in if there had been
an open court system he would have won
but you know the authorities came to him
and said mmm
don't go any further and I mean there
was only and the judges were also told
don't go any further
so but there are places where he can
make make his mark and and he continues
and it just an extraordinary
extraordinary guy but I mean I keep
asking him why don't you I mean he's I
mean he's gone through he's been
imprisoned he's been you know he's gone
up and down as you as you note and but
and
asked him finally why don't you leave I
mean you've got a lot of money somehow
still and he does not to Russian and I'm
too old you know and that's it
what's it like reporting in Putin's
Russia particularly outside of the
Moscow Petersburg axis it was really
easy for the longest time I mean it or
seemed to be mean people I mean
certainly in the pre Putin error I
couldn't stop people talking in the 90s
and and even in the even in the early
2000s and then and they and then after I
had retired in 2011 and was able to go
back for long periods of time for the
first time I would I mean I kept going
back even when I was in Iraq but it was
only for you know a week a year and
emails and but I thought everything in
2012 sort of ok and then they called me
in and sort of went no it's not okay
actually you have to leave but I got in
visa the next year bureaucratic
inefficiency okay one hopes and the guy
who expelled me is in jail for
corruption I mean all the Russian
friends said but didn't he want a bribe
and I said I I sort of said is there a
way to solve this problem
and he did not pick up on it so he
wasn't gonna take one for me but he
apparently had taken them from everybody
else and is paying for that but and then
the next year I had similar problems and
they took but they didn't expel me that
time but they took me into the police
station while they I think we now
realize they said they could go and get
my computer and see what was on it and
whatever but so it was and friends have
you know are called in and have been
called in and said you know she's a spy
she's a very nice woman but she's a spy
I mean after all what pensioner is is in
you know going to chili ovens I mean
nobody in their right mind would go
there on her own dime and and now I just
got an email yesterday from friends
saying that you know they don't
anticipate I'll probably be able to go
back but and they say that things are
just getting worse
I mean it's not getting better the
crackdown they've all been called
foreign agents not because of me and
people who were working with NGOs and I
mean in things that had nothing to do
with politics for the most part thank
you if you go back if you went back what
would you want to know what would you be
looking for I'd actually want to know
what the kids are thinking you so you
have a chapter where you've hung out it
about sort of the chelyabinsk equivalent
of a charter school sort of more
privileged well for smart kids not just
privileged but smart yeah yeah and but I
didn't instill you with a lot of hope
for the next generation no either they
knew that they could get out because
they were really brilliant scientists
computer types physicists whatever
winning the Olympiads for all of those
subjects in in Russia and that they
could they would go to Moscow and then
they'd go to Stanford or MIT or Oxford
Cambridge they knew that they had a way
out
and if they didn't and and they were
quite patriotic too there was an element
of Putin in all of them so if you went
back you'd want to find out what became
of those kids yeah and whether their
attitudes have changed and I can't there
there's you know a class of sort of
upper middle class businessmen that I
got to know a few members they were very
leery of me although they all have kids
who are in school here they there's a
human as in the US at fifty grand a year
they have they there's a raging business
in Miami for Russians and from chili
ovens too who have babies there and get
citizenship and I never got a good
explanation from the State Department I
mean when somebody comes you know out to
here and ask for a visa I mean it's
pretty clear maybe they got the visa too
they thought early and got the visa two
years but if you deceives family
planning yes but if you deceive them
that child actually can have the visa
the citizenship revoked they don't do
that
so I mean somebody's I it's a that's
another issue I would like to explore
further because it's a it's a there's a
business in Miami who deals with
Russians
we have translators they take them to
the hospital they find them you know
they're there for the birth they
translate everything if the people I
mean it's up wait'll Donald Trump hears
about that if you give you guys a shot
if you have questions Patti's got a
micro please use the microphone it's
lovely to see you again
and after 36 years yes I look just go
just look forward to reading your book
you said in the beginning that Stalin
was getting more and more
well loved as time went on communism
isn't though apparently and neither is
you know the desire to wall themselves
off from the West so what what explains
that well I always felt that I mean when
the Soviet Union broke apart all the
other constituent republics could blame
Moscow and the Russians for everything
and they they didn't bear any
responsibility not even you know even
though they did I mean there was never
really in accounting and and they could
they could dredge up all of their
folklore and things that have been
buried and and it was Russia that was
bad it was Moscow and and just another
reason why Russians felt beaten up and
they too didn't know what was good in
their past and it was hard and you know
for it you know as for a while as you
well know and I mean in the 80 late 80s
and 90s I mean the you know report I
mean people were writing about their
suddenly revealing what had happened in
their families and reading about the
gulag and in a way that I had to the
point where actually kids would say
enough already okay I want to go listen
and
so I think that's part of it and Stalin
well they're historians now I mean it's
not just Stalin but it's a friend of
mine who's a historian at Chelyabinsk
University and a very good one I mean he
was he was going to a meeting with
foreign other a conference where there
would be foreigners and he was called in
beforehand and said you will not reveal
anything that reflects badly on this
country so how do you discuss history so
it's shutting down and if if indeed you
do want access to certain archives you
will not be allowed to travel abroad now
so that limits academics in terms of
what they will look into or not and the
other thing is that I was really lucky
that I met with the archivists and
gotten to know them in 2011 and 2012
because now when I see them I see them
in coffee houses not at the archives
they would not be allowed to meet me
and I'm sorry to default to the obvious
breaking news question but how should we
all think about the Trump Putin tango
how do you think about it well there's
sort of peas in a pod aren't they
there's a lot better than trumpet no I
all I only feel comfortable saying that
I think that the phenomenon of Trump
it's very similar the Putin phenomenon
I mean he's playing to you know will
make the country great again I mean
that's what Putin has successfully I
mean it's sort of ironic the Putin I'm
sorry no I I'm not I'm not equipped to
answer the question it's a good one
though sorry I have to ask a trunk
question so I do a trap built in New
York the condominium hotel and other
buildings which he helped prompt built
in New York with the help of Russian
oligarchs I think one name was Felix
Atta did did you come across these
people I didn't know that they like to
us for you have them say I'm sure they
probably go to the same clubs I got
similarly it's not not my area
hi Anne in Okinawa with the Committee to
Protect Journalists my question is what
should or what would the American media
do better in reporting Russia today I
think get out of Moscow I mean seriously
when's the last time you saw anybody get
out of Moscow except maybe to go to
Ukraine and I mean I sort of gave a
shorthand but I mean I was I was not
there and I was reading the media from
Iraq and or wherever and oh and 10 2010
11 and if if I had just relied on that I
would have thought the whole country was
you know in opposition well that's not
true
and we may not I mean all of our friends
you know basically or I mean our friends
are back in the kitchens no talking they
said they would never go back well
that's where they are because and or on
blogs where they hope where they're not
putting their head above the transom
somehow they're not so important that
anybody's paying attention to them but
you can be you know fingered for the
craziest things so I mean I think we
need to explain why and we it may be
distasteful we may not want to
appreciate or understand why people like
Putin but I think that we need to you
know what mistakes did did we make
mistakes as Americans in terms of
treating Russia like a loser why is it
that the that Russians are increasingly
I mean anti-western whereas it is you
described this one friend of mine who or
acquaintance of mine it was a magazine
editor and I mean dresses in the
fanciest western clothes but you know
Lowe's the West I mean they're it's all
oh and is this is this gonna last does
this have staying power are there red
lines
I think we need to keep asking those
questions rather than just sitting in
the kitchen listening to our friends
bolon you know and the opposition you
know is is you know Putin has
brilliantly played on them
he's divided and conquered them with
absolute ease because they've eaten
themselves for lunch and so we need to
look more critically at what happened
there rather than sort of just saying oh
it's Putin it's Putin well it's I'm
sorry unfortunately it's also the
opposition I hate questions to
journalists about prediction predicting
the futures and so now our job is what
happened yesterday not what happens
tomorrow but I've I mean what you're
saying sort of suggests that putinism
will outlive Putin or be worse I mean
quite possibly I mean I mean they're you
know several of this sort of successful
upper-middle class people I know sort of
are going along with it because you know
you it could be worse
and I don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow but that's sort of why I said
what can we do we have to sort of accept
the fact that it exists and and and it's
not just Putin as a personality writing
books about Putin but putinism know as a
and and there are these and and I I'm
just beginning to learn about them and
now in Chelyabinsk I mean these new
fights that are going on between
different groups I don't know to what
degree it's a threat to Putin or if it's
just local or I mean but it's pretty
nasty
and and I think we need to look at those
and there were things that I really
loved in your book there are a couple
things that I really hated that you what
hate it hate it hey did you know that
word hate it's big in American politics
what I thought was particularly
wonderful was when you were talking
about Amway because in contrast to some
slug-like Jeffrey Sachs my my is the
soft power of American and Mary Kay
showing how people can take some
economic entrepreneurial role in their
own lives and I wonder if you could talk
just a little bit more than you did in
the book about what the example of that
kind of limited entrepreneurship
catching on in teaching people did to
not kid so much as middle-class people
schoolteachers and on people have been
bureaucrats in changing how they saw
what they could do with their lives and
what I hated in your book I think you
yeah I think somebody has to stand up
for more cynical I think you made him up
into a straw man I don't think he's set
out to have a corrupt regime taking out
I think he knew what he was against but
didn't know what he was for and and you
know lost control and I thought some of
your sentences setting up the contrast
of Putin chinna with what Yeltsin tried
to do were we're frankly wrong I mean I
think even Yeager guides our fat little
pig that he was understood that blue
harness notion of enrich ourselves
it's just who got to enrich themselves
but really like the Amway pot
that's what you call a mixed review yeah
were you the one who wrote it on the
enough no I mean what was exciting
beginning in 2000 was the emergence of
the middle class I mean it did they had
to start with they had all been
scurrying around you know trading going
to China going to Poland going wherever
they could to buy goods and sell on the
streets in the freezing cold and get and
then running to the bank to I mean
everybody I mean even in the villages
became a foreign currency expert and
then this stability began to emerge in
2000 you could finally get you know a
mortgage credit begin to build a
business and and there were lots of
opportunities if you were smart whether
it was building steel doors or or double
paint triple pane windows or Amway
curves big deal in Chelyabinsk you know
stores you know the commercial world
exploded restaurants an Irish pub no
sushi Chinese you name it and or and
really high-end so I mean there there
was things were really growing and
moving and the crash of the but it
didn't none of that really consumer
goods were still all imported food was
largely imported good food
other than cabbage and whatever hmm yeah
well that became harder and harder that
was not to get I mean it wasn't like the
old days
but but you know that I thought maybe in
2012 when everything began to the
economy began to shrink and I mean
literally people's incomes shrank from
2012 to 2015 by 30 30 percent at least
and I thought that was going to be the
red line no people bought it ate it said
this is going to be good for us we're
going to become self-sufficient and food
they bought even though Putin and his
government has not made it easier to
create and grow businesses and hasn't
been that generous to agriculture
nonetheless people believe it want it
and and that red line has not been the
red line I thought it might have been hi
so uh thanks for the book
congratulations it sounds like you've
crystallized so many things going on in
modern Russia that those of us who've
been in and out of the place for years
are seeing going on so my question is if
you had a magic wand and you could
change one thing about Russia today hmm
what would it be
that's not my job I mean well of course
I'd remove fear if I could because
increasingly if it's if fear is too
strong a word caution has become the by
word
and that makes me sad it's like you know
as a friend of mine set in in 88 89 I'm
out of the kitchen and I'm never going
back well they're back in the kitchens
the conversations that's where they
happen in this great great answer on the
spot but the the fear what about a
little bit analogous question to media
coverage a little bit analogous to the
question about media covers what about
American foreign policy and the
implications of what what do you think
is the awareness and appreciation and
understanding of Putin's domestic
popularity and positions and how does
that relate to American foreign policy I
guess I'm talking about the current
administration well Tom Graham actually
is a pretty good piece today where was
it foreign policy I don't know but I
mean it just there are things that we
can do with them that we need to do with
them and I mean we can't just i mean
we've worked with them in the soviet
period when it was as bad on key issues
and we need to go back to that and i'm
not you know now the russians know more
about our sins of which there are many
and we haven't you know we've got so
many problems of our own I frankly find
it I find our finger pointing on human
rights I think we have to be more
nuanced more careful I mean not that I
we should ignore those things but there
are other issues where we really can
maybe work together we're all we're
coming from it with different priorities
but and Graham you know points out a lot
of you know the difficulties but I think
we have to I mean we can't just walk
them out we can't ignore them we can't
ignore their concerns I mean Russia is a
country with you know
a huge nuclear arsenal
it's got enormous natural wealth it do
we really want to push him towards China
do we I mean there are lots of questions
about you know what works for us and not
but I think we just have to be really
clever about how we and handle it do you
do one more Annie thank you so much for
having dedicated this time all these
years I'm really looking forward to the
book I want to go back to sort of the
day-to-day reality and wondered if you
had found much change in the education
system from the rote learning approach
of all those years until the sort of
opening and the the breakup of the
Soviet Union where more critical
thinking was being introduced into some
of the schooling that always strikes me
when I think of the propaganda that is
accepted as being one source really easy
acceptance that it looked like that sort
of thing was changing but the the rote
learning still continues and I mean
there I mean there of the charter school
sort of that I described which is really
a school a science tech I mean they're
taught to think not I mean it's a very
special place but I full bright scholar
who was there a couple of years ago was
at the teacher training college and she
was giving she was using TED Talks for
to encourage development of English in
which she was teaching and and she chose
one in particular that was sort of
analyzing the educational changes and
that needed in the educational system
here and and it was a it was a great
discussion and she then
pose questions the kids who were 1920-21
Union teacher training college and I
said oh that's not for us that's for the
authorities and it was just a minute
this is 2014 I mean it might as well
have been 1981 it was so depressing and
and that's I mean you see it again and
again and again the book is Putin
country it's I highly recommend it round
of applause for Annie girls
[Applause]